fire
stop
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
yeah we're good chin good the cardigan
today daddy oh yeah that's a great by
the way that's a [ __ ] gangster
cardigan that's the kind of thing a
gangster would wear chin I want to get
to the one from uh emotionally
unavailable the black one yeah I'll do
that are Cardigans coming back because
I've seen them a lot I wear them I have
several of them I almost wore one today
I have a tie-dye one but then you know
what I'm I'm never gonna go baggy jeans
but I'm going loose surgeons because I
saw a clip of me in the cardigan with
some uh really tight looks like the
letter Y no I look like I looked like
Gru from the movie Despicable Me it
looked ridiculous I saw the clip I
looked at my brother and Mark I'm like
why don't you tell me that'll happen
sometimes that I've clocked that I I
I've looked here I went he looks very
much like the letter Y I look
uncomfortable well you taper all the way
down to those little calves because I
gotta show but I get the big difference
but take it easy what I'm trying to say
is this your shoulders go on for days
you're gonna have to bleep out oh yeah
first minute I can't help it I know I
love
hey you're gonna bleep that up please
weiner please be
please be more disciplined about your
language in the beginning well yeah the
big quads you want to show those off you
know you know your quads oh dude don't
start they're not giant you're a big guy
oh man your sizes your size is in your
back your shoulders your arms your neck
and all that and and you have that you
have that regular and you have that
regular thing now listen
uh your calves and your thighs and yeah
I've been meaning to talk to you about
your bum right you know what calves are
for they're they're for nothing right
for sprinting yeah you want big cats no
big calves people are not fast like no
but but here's the thing
like don't talk about your thighs
because nobody and nobody knows them oh
dude you know what I mean oh no but
nobody knows it won't compliment I get
no no but you you say Juan Barkley's got
thighs right like those are well he has
all the thoughts yes but you have you
have like shredded no no no
they're strong thighs but they're not
that big Mark Harley has thighs he's got
big thighs I always make fun of most of
my life people would be like what what
is wrong with your legs
what's that Thigh Master yeah exactly
um now B where where were you because it
was it's very
yeah that's I would like to kiss we
haven't seen each other in quite some
time we talked about this so you went to
London you told me you were there for
business and then you know I'll see
social media but Jade go you see Brian
he's hunting in in the stupid hat don't
wear those hats right yeah he's like
then stupid huh oh I thought he was
there for business years no it looks
like he's just hunting so
if you're going to leave them vacation
you've had several of them this year
yeah you're older you want the world no
but if you're going to leave just tell
them don't lie no I'm not lying
I'm not lying look your excuse changed
several times did it uh movie TV I'm
doing stand up for corporate
yeah okay
I'm doing a movie in L.A though in L.A
now the the the the London thing
was for fun and I don't tie anything a
business
yeah day of Business by business you
mean your friend was like how's business
going this and you went good he went
thank you no there's there's right on
there's performance involved but but but
mainly it's true that I shot a lot of
pheasant Partridge out of the sky with a
shotgun
I I committed mass murder in the sky and
where were you at what they do is they
flush the bushes they drive yes and with
people and they drive all the birds to
the air and then you blast away it's a
harvest you have a group of poor Birds
it's a harvest guy but then I eat the
birds I eat my Partridge not all of them
the rest we we give to people using a
shotgun use a 12 gauge shotgun so you
can't miss and I shot myself I did shoot
myself a deer I did throw it over my
shoulders did you see that video I sent
you I saw it so threw it over my
shoulders I struggled walked in about a
thousand yards to uh my buddy's shed not
a shed it's bigger than most people's
houses no part of my problem be with
this is
um the hats you were wearing yeah
like and don't wear it backwards well
you're trying to do it do it I know but
when you're hunting you want to have
you've gotta in England you've got to
have your your British hat on yeah but
they don't wear it backwards I
understand now that rifle has a silencer
a sound suppressor on it oh just in case
the birds heard you no that's that's for
dear now I heard the I heard my bullet
hit the deer perfectly died immediately
I heard it the thwap of it and I was I
knew I had done it yeah
so it was a good time overall though it
was a great time I I here's the thing
actually I'm glad you're asking I drank
the best wine in the world I ate caviar
I ate the best food in the world I I
gorged some of the best cheeses sure I
saw my my friend Adam duritz at the
Counting Crows that great Band in
concert it's all good
but when you get older and you're doing
all of that
it doesn't make you feel good the next
morning yeah oh you look you Gorge yeah
your face is a little yeah you're like a
foie gras goose and you're fighting jet
lag there's a lot of [ __ ] yep
when I think back on it the time the
time I like the most might have been
when I was in a cold plunge I got on a
cold plunge and it was painfully
uncomfortable and I was like this
actually feels better in uh London my
buddy has a cold Plunge in his home it's
a new rich guy thing that's right hole
plunge is like uh you know it was like
it's like you know dude
but now pool plunge's new sauna Cole
plunge sauna cold plunge everyone's
trying to beat Death and yeah Dr Death
goes
you think the Cold's gonna do it now now
here's what I appreciate about you
you don't um you've never worried about
death and you're like I'm probably gonna
die at 70. I'm gonna get my kicks before
the whole [ __ ]
goes up in Flight I'm not here for a
long time I'm here for a good time to
quote the great Jim Morrison yes and
there's something about people who are
into anti-aging that bugs me me too it
[ __ ] bugs me too do you want to live
till you're 120. let me ask you a
question you ever see your average 100
year old you want to extend that look
and worse for another 20 years I've seen
Biden you know what I'm saying get that
and he's 80.
well have you ever seen the average 100
year old they look at they look like
what you put on your porch at Halloween
especially especially in American 100
like some of the Japanese and the other
ethnicities now listen they're not
spraying chicken bring up images of 100
year olds let's take a look at what they
yeah do you I I guess I won't be around
so I can see my kids but hopefully I'm
all there now Daddy's brain it's me
swiss cheese by the time it's going to
be sweet give me some holes at a hundred
and and how how much longer and for what
you can't even go for a walk and by the
way the animals want to kill well chin
go back now no go go go go uh far
farthest right that's me at a hundred
that's me that's that's same nose same
limit yeah there you go that's me at
100. that's 100 year old now do you want
to uh now would you pull up in the
mirror and be like 20 more years and
there's Brian no there's Brian go down
uh the third roaching second third right
no right that's right there here's Brian
that's Brian he's got no teeth
it's still on the show yeah just doing
his thing and still with a lean face
doing the best I can that's a hundred
you're you're your body's not meant to
be alive that long my only thing is is
you know they grew up rough right and
technology and science is a little more
advanced now so you I figure like the
like yeah in 2050 yeah it's gonna the
100 year old is gonna look a little
different yeah if I can look 25 you know
what I'm gonna look like Jen uh bring up
uh uh Transylvania 3 the bad guy oh
that's it's gonna be me at 100 years old
this with technology everything 23 bad
guy there you go sorry they say the
first person amazing how you remember
these things see in the far left there I
am on the out of a machine
now in my head you'll be you'll be a
walking lung that's why I'm gonna be an
iron lung and just a head
yeah this is Abraham Van Helsing there
you go you'll be Abraham Van Helsing
will you merge with technology to extend
your life well yeah I don't know
at what point for what so my kids come
and visit a computer and I talk to him
yeah how are you yeah I wanna I wanna
what did you do today
yeah I I just don't get it and by the
way
I've I've heard from certain scientists
that those anti-aging drugs age you
faster they don't work
I don't know anyone I mean somebody's
just genetics dude somebody is just it's
the luck of the which ones which all of
it I'm referring to
let me name one dude David Sinclair
who's got and these guys who all have
these uh these all these anti-aging
drugs yeah from what I understand like
these yeah the shots the shot the big
boys look at how much they are immunity
immune well you kiss them I don't
understand there's not necessarily a
whole lot of evidence but you know why
it's a vertical all those yeah
um agreed but you know you know why that
why it's so expensive because the people
that are into anti-age and stuff like
that it's the rich really who because
they have nothing else to worry about
they're not worried about paying their
bills they're not worried about those
things so then you be it's notice the
richest people you know are the ones
that tell you about oh I met with this
new nutritionist I'm doing this new diet
I have this new HGH hey this this new
cold plants hey have you tried uh you
know cryogenic and you're like whoa oh
you don't oh you've checked every box so
now you just focus on health that's
that's what that's exactly that's all
that's going on that's exactly you're
the richest celebrities the women who
are obsessed with it they've checked
every yes they don't have to worry about
their bills and their kids and their
private school and all that [ __ ] that's
right and so so what you want to do is
you want to keep this thing going my
buddy told me that my buddy's uh famous
guy and he's friends with all these
famous people he said when I'm around
these people who have a billion dollars
and they have everything and all they
have now is they just want to keep it
going so the if you you you can't get
their attention about anything the
minute you start talking to them about
anything that has anti-aging properties
they're like this like what where
because why is that it's the one thing
they can't control that's right ages one
thing now I give you [ __ ] about looking
90. but as far you're 55 B 54 yeah you
have great genetics yeah I do me at
video I mean my dad looks good but I've
lived a rougher life I don't know how
I'm only at 55 but you have 55. my thing
is my thing is when I see like a seven
or eighty-year-old when they're in shape
I give them all the respect if they're
like on a Clean Diet 100 healthy diet
some of them are vegans or keto or
carnivore yes and they're like actually
in shape and they're not you know
they're they're fighting the good fights
but they're really they have discipline
that's why I'm like that's what I want
to be yes because they're doing it they
want to be around longer maybe they have
grandkids or something like that that
that's what I respect I gave not the
people with the Botox and all that I
gave a guy like a lot of like a
compliment he was 90. and he looked he
was at least 90 and he and he was in
such good shape this was in England this
past week he was in such good shape and
he was just like he had his hair and he
looked [ __ ] deep lines I mean he was
old but he kept his body ramrod straight
he was strong as [ __ ] and he was an
outdoors guy he was leading one of the
bird things you know and I was like dude
you stand [ __ ] I respect right yeah and
then uh he goes yeah and then I saw him
smoking and I was like this
[ __ ] gangster I go damn I go
and I'm like damn 90 this 90 something
year old guy still smoking and then I
found out he was 71. oh yeah smoking at
Asia the smoker age the [ __ ] out of you
like man this 99 year old he's like I'm
sick ah that was like the guy I told you
that story about meeting um this that
guy who was like 80 but he looked like
an 80 year old Sean Penn right yeah he's
like like he looks so much it was like
this when Sean Penn's 80 you know years
old that's going to be Sean Penn and I'm
talking to him talking to my buddy and
then I realized it was Sean Penn
what happened to your butt yeah he was
just so frail maybe let's take a little
break you and I we haven't seen each
other so there's some Chatty Cathy it's
been a while I want you to know that um
I had a taste of athletic greens I was I
went hunting I was in London and my
buddy who heard us talking about
athletic greens got athletic greens he's
made all the money he's been all the
success and he actually every single day
I got myself some did you guys just put
the athletic greens into one eight tasty
eight ounces of water shook it stare at
each other went good luck animals and
then that's right and I'm going to tell
you it's like innocent Birds well when
you're gonna go shoot and you if you're
gonna hunt if you're gonna get if you're
gonna be physical that day I really want
75 minerals vitamins I mean why would
you want minerals why wouldn't you want
Whole Food sourced ingredients why
wouldn't you want a multivitamin a
multi-mineral a probiotic green superflu
blend and More in one serving okay
you're talking about bioavailable it's
one of the one of the few products I
bring on the road with me every morning
when I'm doing stand up I'm on the road
I don't feel great ag1 gets me feeling
fantastic join the movement of athletes
life lights moms dads rookies
first-timers comedians podcasters your
aunt your uncle everybody's in age and
here's the thing athletic greens can
give you immune supporting free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit athleticgreens.com fighter
athleticgreens.com fight or take control
your health and give ag-1 a try you take
care of your body you take care of your
muscles you wear nice clothing
you wear a hat what's going on with your
brain do you do you do you nourish your
brain are you taking a nootropic I want
you in the Flow State and everyone's
like oh you can take two easy pills I'm
like there's nothing like that Alpha
Brain from on it I knew it dude and then
even Brogan our good buddy Rogan was
like dude I use it helps me form better
sentence I remember when Rogan invented
Alpha what basically was researching the
tropics and put the ingredients and see
he believed in it so much he goes don't
even buy the product here are the
ingredients do it yourself yeah he's
never looked back never it helps you in
that flow state so if you want to get a
little smarter form better senses
remember names that we got you covered
man memory mental space Focus if you
don't like caffeine a jittery feeling
Alpha Brain is caffeine free on it and
Alpha Brain and us we're so positive
that you're gonna love Alpha Brain if
you don't you get your money back just
give them two weeks at that point you
don't love Alpha Brain but you will just
tell them why they refund your money on
the spot no return essay so save 10 by
going to on it.com slash f-a-t-k that's
on it.com slash fatk you get ten percent
off Alpha Brain workout gear on it
supplements protein powder creatine fish
oil krill oil multivitamins they got it
all go to audit.com
f-a-t-k Safe temperatures off or go pick
up some Alpha Brain at your local
Walmart but help your friends out here
go to audit.com f-a-t-k 10 off now let's
get back to the program now B should we
get into it I want the fans know I did
uh cash app Brian two thousand dollars I
appreciate it you gave me that two
thousand rights right after the fights I
wired you the 2K yes yes no no and and I
did say this I want to caveat with this
when you you took much of I took Charles
Oliveira and my point with the BET and
you know it's not that I'm not a
microchip fan it was like my whole thing
was because I've been been so long I've
heard how great guys are from so many
people until I physically see it on
paper and I see it in person I can't
co-sign that now I I get it now my chef
is the rare is the rare occasion I would
say where they were spot on he did walk
through Charles Olivera he is the real
deal he's going to be champ for hit with
his style and he doesn't take much risk
he's me a champ for a long he also
strikes remember he knocked Oliveira
down with a punch yeah dude with a hook
that that was the most to me like when I
saw strike I'm like oh my God I know
even Frank I go you're doing him a
disservice because him and khabib are
two totally different people they're
different one is very good at everything
yeah and khabib was the best ever do it
at One Thing Mark Chev is damn good at
everything but here's what people Miss
on this whole thing and I talked about
in the shop show
B imagine let's say
25 years ago
30 years got that when uh khabib's
father they call it the father's plan
when he when he had uh islamak and
khabib as young 22 years
no I didn't know 22 years
think about a coach right now going
they're two young boys let's say they're
10 or 8 years old and he goes uh these
two will not only be great Fighters
they're gonna be best to ever do it at
lightweight you would you like that
Serena Williams you make fun of them
King George can you you make fun of them
you make fun of them you're like yeah
you're like if they even get to the UFC
goes oh yes no no they're easing at the
UFC the only do you see they're gonna
you ready they're gonna be the best
lightweights to ever do it he's gonna be
the first he's gonna retire and then
he's going to take over and be even more
dominant and this one will go down as
the greatest to ever do it it's crazy
is that an eye for for because see to be
like good you it's not just Talent it's
it's you got to have somebody that
sticks to two things that sticks to it
yeah that that is that has the will to
win and has their own internal clock
where they they they are their own coach
like you don't have to motivate them I
think it's Josh Thompson I went you're
right man
yeah so Josh was telling you well he
came to my shot San Jose Improv he's in
the mean green and saying language get
up you know what I'm saying come here
and he goes hey you're a great shot
forget about all this down Charles
Oliver Mark Jeff how's it going Daniels
oh dude hey you know uh Josh likes
drinking he's a little junkies and I you
know he was like much of walks through
him man it's one of the easiest fights
oh you've been drinking and he goes meet
me at the bottom yeah see you there see
you later dude you know and I was like
yeah out of your mind and Josh knows
fighting oh dude the captain of AKA and
he came up with uh he was Mark chess all
the story of I've heard I'm like this
validates everything when I heard John
Fitch say if he can stand up against
khabib now John Finch is 205 pounds
walking around
and John pitch said he John Fitch
you know John Fitch said when I can
stand up against khabib in a in a
practice if I if I get to my feet that's
a win and I went hold on John fish you
ground everybody down to a pulp not for
a title yeah I mean and I'm looking at
how he's built and I'm like how the [ __ ]
you know so and Market chapter the other
thing is Market Jeff walks around at uh
200 pounds 190. but be thinking about
this think about this this is the rumors
I was hearing they go we've never seen
Kobe Blues around against DC Kane Luke
you name it he's never lost around he's
lost rounds to Islam Islam's the only
guy who beats it yes I went I went what
why won't you tell me this before I made
the bet I didn't know that oh yeah
that's why we say he's the best of all
time we've seen him go against khabib in
his prime Islam was just coming up and
he would he's the only guy we've ever
seen beat khabib and now it didn't
happen often yeah but he's the only guy
we've ever seen actually get rounds
against
give people an idea of how good these
guys are who are professionals like John
Fitch told me he goes I went to a jiu
jitsu school and John's pretty modest
guy and he goes I was a little nervous
because there are a lot of black belts
there and I was like I'm going to roll
with these guys and you know I don't
know I mean I I and then oh John's a
freak he starts smashing all the Black
Ops he goes oh yeah I'm John Fitch hold
on I do this as a living he was like oh
these guys don't no John's this is my
life and these guys do it as practice oh
doubt now here's another one can bet on
obviously we have the the izian uh Alex
Pierre fight which we have big money on
that one you know that's five grand yes
I'm up two grand now I think I'm up all
together
did I win last time I can't remember my
Viking pan we bet I forget what it was
but yeah you hear me out on this Alex
volkanovsky Islam actress happening I
think it's February March in Perth
Australia that's happening that's clear
of the pet so you have the lightweight
belt on the line yeah you have the uh
145 belt on the line any of the pound
for pound
number one spot on the line so three
three titles who do you got a couple
thoughts on this because I want to keep
breaking down what happens you know the
odds
don't tell me the odds yet but I'm gonna
make it I'll tell you before Oh I'm
going to give you a couple odds
[ __ ] volkanovsky's striking first of
all if you saw what vulcanovic how thick
he was when he went up and stood next to
Market Jeff you go well that's his
weight class
he's very very big and strong so I'm not
it's not I'm not worried about size not
strengthening no now now if if you stand
and bang with volkanovsky whoever you
are you're you better be very careful
because he hits with so much Power Max
Holloway correct so he's got some
otherworldly striking
and he hits you so [ __ ] hard now he
doesn't necessarily knock you out
remember remember two of those guys who
are 145ers did not get knocked out they
took all the damage they didn't get
knocked out Max always used to be a 55
though to be if I'm gonna say it now now
Islam marketev is going to win that
fight yeah because there's no way in a
million years that volcanovsky with all
due respect to him
has any answer to that guy when he grabs
you I agree if there's nothing you're
doing you're gonna you're gonna end up
on your back and if you think tcd almost
choked you out it's going to be a bad
bad time for anyone when he gets you
he's going to wear you like a sweater
and he's got a thousand ways to break
your [ __ ] back and that's fine and
you know what it's been a tough he's a
killer you go back to 45. you still
dominate 45 dude but you got to keep
losing weight Bubba there's a lot of
condemnity fight until he knows he's
coming at 55 so he's put on some there
he goes right now now let's wait now the
odds are ready before we bet and yeah as
he gets closer I guess I'll bet on it
but March has a four to one favorite
he's a he's a he's a minus four I
understand that me too
what I want I'm with you and you're spot
on I don't know what we're going to see
what answer he's gonna have for his
grappling here's what's going to happen
it's what's going to happen Chef is
going to get the belt he's then going to
go to 70. and he's going to play around
up there
and he's gonna he's gonna he's worth to
do at 55 though he can't jump this he's
got work to do at 55s
I'd like fights I'd like to know who at
55. has anything to say to him and I
want to get into that because because
volkanovsky will go back down to 45 and
then volkanovsky will come back up now
I'd love to see volkanoski fight
Charles Olivera me too I bet that's
something I'd like to watch me too
um volkanowski gives anybody at 55 a
problem except for Market Jeff so we got
at 55 Dustin Poirier
um now hold on before you go on yeah
that's important Michael Chandler are
gonna fight
the winner that probably gets a title
shot and then I think they're gonna do
Charles Olivera and
um banil dirush which is a great fight
darush could have some answers for
buckchup on the ground Savage I don't
know I wish I could believe that I know
it's tough and I can't joke and you know
what Bubba you know what I'm not know
what Bubba anymore
Islam Islam and I love Dustin I love
everybody there Islam mochachev and look
at my mouth when I say this
ain't here in a [ __ ]
peep
out of anybody at 55. I'm afraid I'm
afraid the the best thing to do is to
sit there for a little while have some
high profile fights Connor please
doesn't want nobody wants Market Chef
that'd be awful for God it's all it's
all terrible everybody there it's all
terrible for mock now now
at 70 no you keep going 70. I know no he
has too much work to at 55. he just
became Champion for him to be the best
lightweight of all time like they say
you you got to break khabi's record and
then keep going to be concerned about
yeah really have to you can't just get
the belt just take all cameras just take
all comments so you know what and he's
going to beat most of them get used to
have some fun at 55 that's what I'm
saying have some get some practice
rounds in 55. don't do respect
him up and then there you go then let's
because if you be his his star Powers
would be crazy because if you beat uh
volkanovsky right nuts and then you
fight you know uh uh Chandler or the
winner between Chandler and does pray
you fight Justin gaichi you fight though
or you fight the winner of gaichi versus
um keichi's fighting physiv yep so
yeah yeah very it's just unbelievable by
the way whatever one street but again we
got we got more Jiu Jitsu more Jiu Jitsu
more against dagestani chain wrestling
and whatever else he does whatever and
oh and the dude can strike yeah he can
strike and also please understand his
submission game is filthy what's called
nasty now me and Frank May were talking
about this with Jesse on fire the
submission he caught uh Charles levarian
there's a defense there all black belts
have most black belts have yeah I think
he got days though me too that's what I
said but the the success rate now you
end up in a horrible position is that to
be on the phone you're here no no see
that's on the phone it's very blue belt
you get choked out okay no you you turn
away from it and you're gonna give up
your back and to be a nightmare but
you're not getting finished okay and the
success rate's about 99 on it so you I
was showing my son's jitsues on Monday
night how to get out of here like this
is what you turn you end up in a
horrible spot but you're not getting
finished yeah it's not a fun time
because now you got to do you're still
getting out of it back now now I'm sure
Michael Jeff has a couple things to say
when he's on your back yeah would you
rather have yeah yeah because he's going
to take your chin and and push it into
your Adam's Apple that ain't fun ask
Connor McGregor about that where'd you
watch the fights I was in uh I was in my
buddy's house his estate oh in London I
watched on a Giants yesterday that makes
a man I know I apologize that's right
um now um now you could have used you on
the companion I had fun yeah but there
was another comic on there right I need
another comic see another comic Frank
Jesse Greg yeah brilliant MMA Minds yeah
but you know they're on the fight
campaign this Saturday but I've got a
comic I got Sam tripley coming silly
yeah a lot of fun I wish I wish you were
there me too let's get let's get Rogan
on the horn let's do another
I can't wait to hear your thoughts on
sugar Sean let's go to codome event then
we get sugar I talked to Sugar's uh
coach Tim Wells tonight I mean this
morning yeah I text with sugar the night
after the fight yep so did I I was very
proud of him
um first of all wait you're going sugar
right now get hold on before you get to
that give me TJ Al Jermaine okay it's a
bummer right because going in and where
are you out on this people are upset
that TJ still took the fight and he knew
his shoulder popped out 20 times going
in the fight this is a fighter this is
TJ TJ Jill is shot he was upset about
him but it's like you don't realize that
they're wondering he's one of the
greatest bantamweights of all time is
because he's that guy who can fight with
one leg he'll fight with his [ __ ]
with one leg he's a different kind of
dude yeah and he's he's he's so tough
that he'll die in there so the question
becomes does the UFC when if they find
out this they didn't find out he said to
the ref he said please don't
oh have you heard about his shoulder
that's like good to know thank you for
telling me you could say his coaches say
TJ
your your shoulder keeps coming out
which means those tendons are too loose
and it it's gonna come out what are we
doing here
um but then then you go you're 36. roll
the dice you're 36. let's roll the dice
probably not getting back there you go
back in the queue yeah so it's like you
know you got a mortgage pay kids you
know payday man and then also Dana in
the UFC always go you know these guys
fight through toughness and you know you
gotta fight injured never pull out a
fight so we're conditioned to do that so
for TJ it's like all these people don't
be mad at him he took two years in his
prime off he has to get going correct
and I don't know if it ever comes back
but no I I I have to say I'm not mad at
him not at all so give him sugar Sean
first of all how do you score it okay so
there are a couple things there are a
couple things about scoring
um let me just say this to overall the
umbrella the umbrella common is this
sugar Shawn proved that he belongs in
the elite you know they ranked them
number one now
bantamweight he's number one that's a
big responsibility but sugar Shawn is a
guy
who comes alive and is at his best when
it all counts he fights the level of his
company he does and he's such a special
dude and he's also like he's also like
all his success like the way he keeps it
going the way he's got somebody always
producing content like his his look he's
the new age fight he's he's amazing he
checks all bugs he's amazing honest
you'll see needed it yes and Tim Wells
said people don't know how hard he
trains people don't know where he trans
people don't know how serious he takes
this [ __ ] no because Jesse on fire is
really close with Anthony Smith I guess
Anthony went out to Arizona train uh and
uh sugar was there I don't know if he's
at the lab or at Sugar's place but they
were like dude this guy's the real deal
the real this is like years ago he's so
like he's the real deal yeah like his
ability with to manage distance his
footwork he's getting better and better
and the fact that he got that look he
went through that that Russian that
Russian to be a tougher fight is such a
bad [ __ ] in every way and you
could say that he got the fights taken
from him in the past three the past
three losses you could make the argument
okay
but uh and so one of the things about
MMA is that he did take sugar down six
times
that's not scored the same way putting
your fist on somebody's faces because
just so you know you're onto some here
the number one judging criteria number
one so they have a checklist yeah number
one is damage correct that's the number
one most important thing when it comes
to fight is damage not takedowns
especially if you take down no damage
take down no control back up take down
back up get back up so even though he
did have more takedowns which me with my
grappling background I do I usually
favor grappling but it doesn't matter
yeah the the judging criteria is not
based off just grappling that's right so
it's the judging if you want to change
the judging and the rules that's a
different story but you shouldn't
because then you're in a wrestling
league yeah and you just get a bunch of
boring fights yeah did Peter Young
control Peter Young was smart enough
like did he control the Octagon I don't
know I just know that Sugar gave as good
as he got in a lot of ways controls the
last judging criteria by the way put his
[ __ ] hands on his face a whole bunch
significant punches absolutely so it
really comes down to the first round
yeah no matter who you are depending if
you're a sugar fan or Peter John fan or
if you have experience well I do think
Peter Young won the first round
but then so you think you get so based
off that you would have to give Peter on
the fight because he definitely won the
second that's clear's day the third
round sugar one the first round depend
High School the first round is how
you're going to score the fight I I see
and I gave a slight Edge to sugar in
that yeah now to be fair to your point
when I was watching again I would say
don't take what I say on the companion
two serious because I'm drinking I'm
trying to manage these personalities and
Frank bear and Jesse I'm not seeing
everything because I'm more worried
about keeping the conversation because
it's not entertaining show yes and I
would just see takedowns and not see a
big hit from sugar take down whatever so
I was like all right first round you
have Peter at the end of the fight went
man I think it's probably gonna go to
Peter yon and Frank and Jessica oh we we
have uh sugar wings I was like really
and then when I saw Kevin aioli who's
who I respect more than anything was
like I have sugar when I'm like oh he's
probably gonna win this thing yeah
because you guys pay more attention than
I was I'm busy working but when I saw
that I'm like oh sugar might win this
and I hope he wins my thing is it was
such a close fight nobody got robbed no
that's what I was gonna say like it was
such a close fight you can say people
got robbed but for me it was like it was
so close and all I was thinking to
myself was that this [ __ ] sugar
Shawn proved he belongs in the same
space as Peter Young nobody would have
said that a year ago oh dude two weeks
ago that's right I mean because it's not
a dis on sugar it's like Peter Yan is as
good as you get he's as good as you get
at everything oh yeah hope he didn't
even in the top three I mean he's
unbelievable but also I think too
because you know the knock on sugar was
oh you know he's he's been marketed by
the UFC they're getting cupcake fights
he's never beat anybody he needs to
prove himself how's he gonna do against
top guy so you know in Sugar because
he's sugar and he does troll people and
do stuff like that when you do that
trust me I get it you're getting a lot
of hate you have a lot of fans we have a
lot of hate yeah welcome to Club sugar
right so you get a lot of that [ __ ] and
so when you when they don't have that
narrative to run on going he's only
fought you know powder Puffs he's been
he's over hyped do you see just doing it
because he's big on social media once
now that narrative is not there anymore
so his haters gonna have to get creative
and come with something else it ain't
there what else do they rank up because
now with the rankings you know it's MMA
media so MMA fighting MMA junkie ESPN
all the outlets have to do the the
rankings they rank him number one and
now you know more about fighting than we
do wow so he's so number one in the
world so the fight is going to be Al
Jermaine Sterling that's the fight yeah
that's happening that's happening
amazing
he's amazing look he's right where he
belongs he's right where he [ __ ]
belongs who you got sugar algeman
um it's tough to base it off of because
if you if you watch the AL Jermaine like
Al Jermaine Peter Young first fight
Peter you know the legal knee really
messed things up but peteron was
destroying second fight different right
controls back once time even though it
wasn't damaged but again based off the
criteria if you go to damage number one
I there's really no damage done number
two would be control takedowns all right
well that's Wayne definitely do that so
he won the fight yeah again pieroni get
robbed he just wasn't able to take
control because ozerman was taking his
back and controlled him and if you go
off we can't go off the first criteria
which is damaged so we're going down the
list here you'd give it to Al Jermaine
so then if you go to algeman TJ I didn't
learn much because TJ did it with one
arm was compromised algeman looked
[ __ ] good he looked so dumb big for
the weight class he looks much bigger
more athletic than anybody wrong
grappling Savage explosive it's hard to
train for that yeah I don't know
it's a hard thing to solve
um
punch in the [ __ ] face and I'll tell
you this algeman seems to be getting
better so is that kid sugar Shawn
O'Malley oh sugar Sean can be twice as
good as you saw him in the Peter John
spot so good he's good right so what a
card man and then Dairy I don't have to
watch Darius I don't know if you watch
Muhammad versus the only one I didn't
watch your boy Brady got okay well now
hold on Muhammad's my boy too he's
buying food truck I love Muhammad Brady
is my guy what happened Brady's first
test he's ranked top 10 he's never
fought a guy at belong Muhammad's level
you look at Who belongs face yeah it was
a young lion and I think Sean Brady will
find out a lot more about him now in his
next fight
he couldn't get him down was forced to
trade with him Allah mohammed's been
there the best he's tough to get down so
then Brady you know got his nose broke
like Muhammad you and you so Muhammad
and Darius you look both those guys
should be fine for a title yeah both
like they have every they've earned
every right yeah the problem is the way
the UFC works now they're probably not
going to get those titles like Darius
you look at who he's beat he's won like
nine in a row some [ __ ] like that 100
should fight for a title
and then you got the winner of uh
Chandler and Poirier you got physiv and
you got uh gaichi so with Darius and
Muhammad they're they're they just get
left behind wow because the marketing
you know even though it's natural and he
wants to give all praise to Jesus which
I you know I have no issue with and his
skill set he's so entertaining to watch
yeah but the UFC is just like no and
then he gets on the mic and goes look at
his record one two three four five six
seven eight in a row one's against Tony
Ferguson one is against [ __ ] Gamera
which is an awful matchup for him he's a
dog in that fight out of those uh wins
he has one two three one two three four
uh performance and five of the nights
he's so entertaining yeah and he's
explosive um he's gonna you know this
they need give him a shot though but TSN
too so he got on the mic he gets on the
mic and goes I don't care about the
title I'll fight 10 guys before they
give me a Top Shot well the UFC and
Hunter Campbell and all those and Sean
Shelbyville okay guys
you know it's like oh man yeah you
[ __ ] yourself yeah because on our
cameras yeah say less oh you don't care
oh cool because it's a nightmare over
here thanks buddy so much hey thanks for
doing a solid for us buddy and then next
thing you know you're gonna be fighting
some other killer gamerat was a [ __ ]
killer you need another killer 55 is
murders Roe well below Mohammed what
what's your how did he beat Brady uh
just punched his lights out detail dude
it was bad yeah well because Brady's a
wrestler and now he's got a exchange
with beloved and he didn't look bad on
feet but you're not what is Bilal
Striker primarily or is he yeah but yes
it is Camp with khabib well that's he's
in that camp yeah so you're not the
Muslim Camp it's gonna be a problem I
say well alhamdulillah you know what you
have when you have Allah when you have a
team of people uh people that pray to
Allah and they're all unified they're
going to be sharing each other's Secrets
Islam is coming you're not allowed to
have 55 convert to Muslims
convert to Islam I want in and I'd get
down and foreign
Church yeah but you you want to be you
want to be with the in the khabib camp
I'm putting you at 55. now look at me
yeah
no nicotine
no drinking no no Rogue no tiger thick
no tiger thick Bubba now hold on yeah
that's it
but now remember when I was fighting I
was not drinking was not doing nicotine
yeah so that actually converted yeah you
got to convert now be a little lucy on
the prey right you guys prayed a little
bit it's too much it's gonna be hard to
keep it's gonna be daydreaming when
you're the daddy's gonna do it daddy's
gonna do it because I need to get with
his training Partners that's right it's
a beast it's a beast but you know what
like like I'm stressed right now right
now you're gonna take a deep breath this
stresses me well the amount of training
like those guys do like do you know what
khabib said to Mike Jeff no the post
fight press conference goes you have two
weeks you have two weeks to celebrate
this now the work starts is that what he
said yeah he's like of course you're
gonna be champ we told you gonna be
champ but now the work starts I have two
weeks off you're back in the training
room I love it and that's just a
different mental Spartan yeah I'll took
six I would have milked this
Championship dude six months of course
I'm in Dubai I'm getting weird where's
the Disco and where's Dubai and where's
where's the room where I can get weird
oh wink wink dude I would get kicked out
of Camp because I'd be on Instagram
snorting lines well I mean or can I ask
you a question I'm naked [ __ ] I want to
ask you a question girls like you girls
like muscular [ __ ] Champions I don't
know I mean I don't know let me ask you
another question are there any girls in
Dubai that are
attractive
in Vegas that are
attracted now a good friend of ours
henzo Gracie told me uh Dubai is Vegas
on steroids I've heard I've been doing
this right now a lot a lot of the a lot
of the prettier girls from say Russia
Romania Bulgaria Vegas I don't know if
you've seen those Eastern European women
but they're very very easy on the eyes
yes and so I like themselves Sophia
sometimes they'll find themselves in
Dubai doing their own thing now now
Fighters Young
wealthy with a lot of attention and very
very good looking muscular chin strap
beards well they well there you go
beautiful women of Dubai look at that
look at that
that's that's an Arabic woman now hold
on for a sec that's that's an Arabic
woman just so you guys know like you
want to talk about some of those
beautiful women in the world and I'm
telling you this they are in places like
Iraq uh Syria I would convert to science
talks they are so gorgeous the Arab
women see this is a big well-kept secret
Lebanon Egypt Iraq it's a secret for
America Syria yeah Lebanon everybody
knows that the Arab women you get that
is that is very common there look at
that gorgeous what are we doing let's
and they usually have a lot of money and
positive attitudes that's a big bank
account and you got that going
and they got to cover up on the street
seriously and they can't not necessarily
and they can't talk right and you can't
talk Brendan hold on and you can't tell
there you go because you wouldn't be in
that girl in the green are you washing
my feet that's not yeah and you watch my
female and you're not talking I I don't
like where this is going any other cover
up no no
oh you're not wearing that but go to
Ferrari girl I'll go to Ferrari girl
that's not that's Lamborghini okay but
either way let me light in the ass don't
come to that light in the ass you got to
be ready for that no it is fantastic
yeah
great fight though I hate you're missing
the companion this Saturday because we
got Jake Paul Anderson Silva which is an
interesting fight but the grooming event
Uriah Hall
Le'Veon Bell to me I'm so into that
because I train with you at Hell forever
in the train room
Savage he's not Savage he's not athletic
at all now he's athletic but not as
athletic as Le'Veon Bell I don't know
Le'Veon All Pro was probably the best
run back in the league for about two
years for the Raiders I'm sorry for the
Steelers in the box now Le'Veon Bell
just knocked out Adrian Peterson bad oh
no Adrian Peter's a little stiff right
now his entrepreneur was a little stiff
isn't that funny now is a freak that's
Adrian Peterson he was fighting yeah by
the way you don't get better you don't
get you don't you're not a better
athlete at the nature and Peter yeah you
don't want him as a dad but yeah is he
no is he still playing or is he not
playing no no no because he's doing
boxing now right so he can't okay so
Adrian Peterson got knocked out bad by
Le'Veon Bell bad by the way so is there
anybody who's a better athlete than
those guys and how does Dave how does
Le'Veon Bell look as far as as a boxer
you look good for not having that much
experience but he's going to fight a
very experienced guy bro I'm telling you
so you know me when people go oh this
this Fighter's an athlete this Fighter's
an athlete and I'm like you've never
seen athletes if you think that guy's an
athlete now Uriah Hall is just as like
if your hall was a little bigger his
explosive his hand-eyed coordination he
has the same athletic ability as a lot
of these NFL players look at this look
at how he's moving so Le'Veon Bell
no I don't like I don't like Adrian
Peterson's hands are down you got to
keep your hands up you're doing that
Adrian Peterson Floyd Mayweather thing
now your boy played against Adrian
Peterson college I didn't know that and
he's not was he fast I've never seen
anything like it yeah all right yes by
the way I'm liking the way the Le'Veon
Bell's moving but he's you see that
stepped at the side no he's a Savage
now the caveat here you know living on
belgus I'm not just doing this for money
or for the fame I like I want a real
boxing career which I appreciate which
I'm like are you staying serious this is
athletic ability but I'm telling you
dude Uriah Hall I know there's no kicks
there's kickboxing kick his freaking
lights out
straight boxing you have a little more
opportunity
but I'm out of all the guys you could
have fought leave on Bill and you're
you're you're you're your biggest
attribute is your athletic ability you
chose the most athletic you're [ __ ] up
because you're at all is just as
athletic as the guys you played with on
this is that true that's good wait a
minute that's coming from me on the
hater on this that's a big statement
Bubba I'm telling you I've never heard
you say me Mark Munoz Pat Cummings
Olympic gold medal in Judo we could not
take this man down what I think you're
full of not to be I think you're being
dramatic you know I think you're being
podcast you're creating drama I'm not
good I'm not I'm telling you you
couldn't date you you couldn't double
leg
your strength Oklahoma State Pat Cummins
All-American
none of us couldn't take them down get
them down you couldn't get them down can
you get them down but now the problem
was is when the lights were bright and
there's a lot of pressure on them and
yes he didn't know I know but in
practice you're saying we couldn't get
them down why well he would his athletic
hips were too good what especially if
there's a cage against wrestlers of that
ill and a guy your style we couldn't do
it your double leg's crazy it's my thing
I took you you name it there's one
Champions I took him you couldn't take
him couldn't get him down how big is he
walking around how big was he on his
training 2 20. oh he's that thick oh but
oh hey Bubba when I say athletic so you
know he knocked out uh gay garden musasi
with a spinning heel kit yes I do which
is insane and you remember and that's
gay guard Musashi by the way oh arguably
the best motivate on the planet even
though he just lost but
um okay so he's 220. but you know where
it is for your eye you know where it is
right here B yeah if if this is right if
this is right yeah he's the greatest to
ever do it really
I've never seen anything like I don't
think he likes fighting that much
he's kind of like a really intelligent
nerd yes yes he's almost too smart
ignorance is bliss right yeah he's very
smart I know a girl who dated him said
he's [ __ ] brilliant now and he
doesn't like fighting that much he'd
rather be having he's a gentle soul no
you know he is he's a real martial
artist yeah he's a real Jamaican yeah
dude I'm telling you so dude oh dude you
know me I'm a hater when it comes to
people calling UFC fighters athletes
I've never this dude is a freak is that
him that's him that's that's fighter
after so he will kick the kid literally
head off that kid like work at Starbucks
now he'll kicked his head off right
Danny goes he's the next answer in Silva
what Dana and this is this is no fault
today now doing the same thing what
Daniel realized is mentally when you put
those labels on your eye and put all
this pressure on him he doesn't do well
that's not what he needed right but they
don't know that no but he's one of those
careers where if his head's right he can
be any middleweight in the world and the
gagar Musashi fight shows that go to his
record chin I'm telling you if he if his
mind right and he wants to be in there
he'll be anybody on any given night now
if it's off you're gonna beat him
you can beat them yeah
um that's astonishing
uh Sean Strickland you lost Weidman you
beat Chris Weidman you'd be dancing
Silva Carlos Jr uh Les Paulo Costa
uh he lost gay guard dick Branson Robert
with her beat Geiger Musashi
lost to Gengar beat Chris leaving he
lost to Derek Brunson Luger Musashi and
Robert Whittaker no but you can see
right you can see how if mine's right
it's not yes you know yes yes
um freak dude I'm telling you Bubba and
for Le'Veon Bell it's like oh dude I
feel like your build is your your one
hand up on all these boxes you don't
have the experience but you don't have
the athleticism where they've never seen
it yeah this guy can go toe-to-toe don't
get it twisted he's not Le'Veon Bell
athletic okay
all pro was the best run back in the
National Football League for a number of
years I don't think people realize what
that that's the crazy not like the freak
like uh Adrian Peterson was a freak but
ran hard he's a freak I'm talking
Le'Veon Bell like his athletic like his
maneuver his agility his his Jukes like
speed quickness he's about 220. yeah
but freak yeah and was very difficult
was so good that they kept that Under
Wraps forever and then we got traded
they realized he was difficulty went to
the Jets it was a bit of a nightmare but
when he was on the Steelers in his prime
All Pro daddy running back in the NFL
Michigan State product like freaked it
and how old is he now probably 35 21.
and and uh that's gonna be the same card
as the comment of it which is so it's
only 30. so he's in the prime of his
life
that's why you don't see a lot of
running backs getting taken high in the
NFL draft because there's such a shelf
life on them that's why they're drafting
you know everybody else yep but he's a
he's a and 38 okay but uh would you say
that uh how is your Iowa's boxing good
good good now his kickboxing martial
arts is better but different game
different sport you know different
distance but just though the Reps and
the sparring yeah now if Le'Veon Bell
goes on knocks him out to kudos to you
because I don't think you're against UFC
record and get all that but I'm telling
if his mind right now I feel like his
mind's gonna be right on this because
it's not a ton of pressure on him he's
got problems the one thing he had was
your athletic ability this kid can match
that now not to your level but out of
all the UFC fighters on the roster he's
the guy that could have probably played
another sport
wow his mind's right he's a freak wow so
we're doing a fight band on that
Saturday 7 P.M Pacific we have uh Frank
mayor Jesse on fire myself and the great
the comic from Hot Tub Time Machine Sam
tripley amazing the 90s comic who's a
freaking monster Savage monster what is
your take on gun to your head and I know
he's your friend but take it out of the
equation you can't but go ahead
Jake Paul Anderson Silva
who you got
you know why it's tough
I don't take all the credit for this but
when Jake and I've said this when Jake
came to my show at the Improv at the
time he's kind of Michael Bisping I said
dude you got to stop doing that Bisping
has one eye two fake knees he's not the
guy you're not gonna get any respect
calling that man out he's moved on he's
on the best podcast one of the best
analytic analysts in the game he's moved
on he's you know he's a movie star now
that's why Conor called him out I'm
telling you that's not the guy you want
to go for I know he's a champion you
want champ if you want to get respect
from that memory Community now you're
never going to get the respect you
deserved because of your background
Disney and YouTube if you want respect
go for answering Sylvie just beat Julio
Chavez Jr
hula Chavez Juniors fit with 5-3
multi-time world champion has the
pedigree like Game of Thrones like a you
know like a Lannister as far as fight
game goes he's a freak gopher Anderson
man because he's he's currently he's Cur
active boxing he just beat a former
world champion go for him he's like you
think I'm like no I know dude go for him
I'm not saying I swayed him on that
sounds like he did shortly after he
announced that fight right sounds like
he did now now you might see Anderson
Silva get old overnight he got knocked
down during sparring from what I hear I
don't know what that means here's the
people that go the fight's in Jeopardy
because they understand he got knocked
out three times it's training so tough
yeah Anderson coach was like no hold on
that never happened all Anderson's
trying to exaggerate how tough his
training was because he wants you to
know he's taking this very serious
nobody knocks the answer not in practice
that's not happening I got it
so what do you think I have to go with
the spider
I just from sheer experience
and and now we're gonna do a Fight Night
flashback after this we're gonna go over
Anderson fights Big Boy Anderson is
every bit as big or Bigger Than Jake
oh he's taller taller taller might be
heavier I mean they're fighting at what
85 what are they fighting he's going to
be taller and obviously his experience
yeah the the problem for me is
does Amsterdam have better boxing all
day long all day long the problem is the
entrance age the miles on from fighting
the concussions from fighting Jake is I
think is going to lose a few rounds but
Jake's in a land one and wobble him he's
not gonna stop the fight Chase Jake has
power and speed in this and when it
comes to this game and Jake's chin has
never been tested I'm sure in training
it's tested yeah but as far as miles
goes you're starting with a clean slate
with Jake Paul so if they're exchanging
non-stop Anderson can have land five or
six and Jake's gonna be fine all Jake
needs is one yeah now it goes against
everything I stand for to pick against
Anton Silva but I would probably side
with Jake Paul in this just because the
off chance of answering getting clipped
by Jake Paul is very high and he's young
and he's quick and he's powerful he
looks great and that's a problem he
looks great I just I I admire that Jake
Paul's willing to do this he's such a I
mean he's got balls man he's got [ __ ]
balls oh dude and again repetitive I've
trained with him so I've sparred with
him sitting at Black House
freak of all freaks and remember
Anderson was gonna was gonna fight Roy
Jones Jr not Roy in his prime but you
know just wrote right over the prime
right about in overtime of his prime not
like years later that was supposed to
happen to Nationals Prime and Roy's kind
of a little bit out of prime but still
he's in straight up box match 12 rounds
The Sign Sealed Delivered then didn't
put the kibosh on it because back then
they didn't want him doing that yeah
because they thought it would look bad
it's Roy Jones would have been yeah a
handful for the person yeah so they
didn't allowed to happen but Anson was
was so good at boxing he was gonna fight
Roy Jones he's very good at boxing yeah
yeah oh dude well I'll say this if Jake
Paul wins I'm not saying ah well
Anderson's old Jake Paul beat a boxer
that beat Julia Chavez Jr now the the
argument for there and you know just
play Devil's Advocate Julio Chavez Jr if
you saw that fight you know his dad uh I
think he's in Guadalajara maybe Mexico
City you know his dad's royalty it
wouldn't the biggest live game of all
time I think it was a hundred and
fourteen thousand in Mexico City will
never be beat we'll just won't will
never be beat but the the caveat there
is they asked the dad Julio Chavez
senior they said um what do you think
about your son he goes he didn't train I
kicked him out of my Camp he wants to be
lazy I'm not part of that I train my ass
off for this fight you know he's like I
took you serious my son's never taken
serious like I have and you see when his
dad won the fight he went over to Canelo
he wanted to you know Canelo Alvarez and
hugged him and that's what he's like his
son because he represents I didn't know
that oh yeah yeah because it represents
Mexico yes and and he's like that he's
like Julio Chavez Jr 2.0 correct yeah
but not as good not as big no you know
and like you got to remember who else I
was Junior her seniors the biggest I
mean he's the most winning Mexican boxer
insane the people are just saying so
much yeah and you've never seen Canelo
Canelo has that same trait where he he
fights like a mixing box yes goes
forward Chavez Jr I mean Julio Chavez
senior bring up what he looked like in
his prime look at his body that's where
you don't judge a book by its cover this
is where you realize he's like I don't
care what he looks like physically he
looked like uh he looked like you know
it's like the Cain Velasquez phenomenon
it's like not the best body in the world
and no you can't you never judge a book
basically he's a Fedor there's so many
examples I don't know why people still
do that just got a regular body you know
when I was uh hired from I mean yeah he
doesn't look like the world beer that's
him now
basically yes maybe a few years ago but
still yeah but that was him
now now
try this out B you know Showtime hired
me to be the representative for MMA the
UFC the the Conor McGregor expert and my
job no matter what was to argue that
Conor could win rounds and land punches
on um Floyd Mayweather I didn't know
that was your job that was my job that's
why you were giving me such uh you
[ __ ] that's my job yeah
literally they were like we don't care
what like that that's your thing say
less and that was pretty right I can't
believe I'm like you you don't think
I've paid to do this I didn't no I
didn't know that no yeah so that was my
thing so they put me on that press tour
I had to go to ESPN argue with Julio
Chavez senior about why Conor McGregor
was gonna land punches it was an
all-maxian show all in Spanish it's him
and two other lights they're allowed in
Spain yeah dude I mean in Mexico bro
I mean try having that job and I'm in a
suit I'm there I'm like oh and I'm like
well do you think that you have
translator and I and before I hit champ
I go champ I said I kept going your
greatness I'm here to argue for him your
Excellency
I will I will wash your shoes after
please don't be mad did you tell him
that you had to go with Connor well he
knew I was there and he he was just like
his you know he doesn't speak English at
all but when I was doing the Connor
stuff the translation
I was like my God talk about selling out
no I didn't know I was right I thought
Connor was gonna plan shots and win some
rounds but you know yeah when you're
arguing with Julio Chavez senior dude
I mean just talk you you know what you
earned your money oh my God you you
worked hard for your money I worked all
the hearts so hard for your money and
then day of the fight they kicked me off
the broadcast
I remember that you were like in the
fast Fierce you're in the back you're
like I'm over here I was like hey how's
it going it wasn't my guys like Brian
dude it was the old heads at Showtime
now you you they know I get loose they
know your boy gets loose oh yeah Lou say
you're passion which is what you want on
there of course I wanted it you know
what I'm doing right now
they're doing well they're put on the
Jake Paul fight oh yeah they have Jake
Paul they have uh some other you know
Javonte Davis is massive and they have
John Javonte who's Javonte fighting next
uh it's probably gonna be Ryan Garcia I
can't I don't like that for Ryan but
this is Ryan's sugar Shawn moment we
like we should be people he has a huge
following on social media yeah he's you
know he's the Justin Bieber of boxing
right he looks good fights good speaks
well they want to be the next Oscar oh
yeah this is this is a I mean this is a
major challenge for him oh did it listen
I love Javonte Davis he's the best
knockout artist in boxing he's musty TV
and he's he's top five pay-per-view
draws in in boxing so he's doing
something right look at that look at
those tats but that being said that
being said if Ryan Garcia were able to
knock Javonte Davis out boxing could use
this
so bad yes he the kid looks good yes he
speaks well yes he talks about mental
health yes he you know he he's he's he
has a podcast he punched people in the
stomach you know what I'm saying like he
does his thing now he's he's the
people's Champion it could be kids in
person no time great kid too smart
really stupid smart
he's a good looking kid Jesus Christ how
much does he weigh
I don't know about outside but if they
were to fight you know you're talking
about so he's got sucked down to 35 is
that what the weight class is he's got
to be five Devonte Davis to go up and
down
bro they had a kid on Showtime boxing
the other week you ready for this yeah
he was I think six six one thirty five
who
but he punches was you know he's too
tall it's like dude
yeah that super featherweight Ryan
Garcia he's getting thicker man this
kid's getting thick he's young you know
how old is he
23
yeah
24 24. he'll put weight on
to be involved in the fight business
fight fighting is a boomer look at him
girls don't like him though right
he has a bunch of kids too he does yeah
I think he has two right I think he has
more already
well he had one of his really young with
baby mama and then you know
look at him yeah you're right two
daughters yeah okay good friends Savage
all right Jim what do you got for us
buddy Mark had to leave Mark's the only
guy Mark just realized because he's
coming to Calgary with me tomorrow I'm
in Calgary Thursday Friday we add a show
Friday because Thursday had five tickets
left so we add a show to Friday at the
rooftop downtown Calgary then next week
two of my favorites coming up next
week's Lo San Antonio I'll be staying at
my favorite Hotel Emma Fair Hotel of all
time great North America never stay at
hotels across outside that but uh San
Antonio's next Thursday Friday Saturday
the week after I'm back in Texas in
Houston Houston Improv and I end the
month in Milwaukee and then uh the rest
of the year touring almost done December
oh he thick toward Providence Rhode
Island's December 1st to the third heard
that's a beast to get to and then
Washington DC DC Improv December 15th
through 17th but Calgary's this week
Thursday Friday pretty sure Thursday's
probably sold out by the time you guys
list this so we add show for Friday
Friday night and then San Antonio is
next week Houston's the following week
then fight companion is Saturday 7 PM
Pacific Frank Mayer Jesse on fire Sam
tripley Jake Paul Elgin Silva Uriah Hall
and Le'Veon Bell get you some thick boy
YouTube Schaumburg Illinois I'm at the
Chicago improv October 27 28 29. that's
tomorrow Friday Saturday come get some
Charlotte North Carolina you're up at
the comedy zone November 10 11 12.
Addison Texas Addison Improv November 17
1819. Naples Florida off the hook
December one through four come get some
let's go
all right Jim what do you got yeah so
Mark's coming with me to Calgary right
he goes and uh he just realized he need
a passport passport he hasn't got he
won't get his passport in time no he he
went through the process he did the
Russian they said you can't pick it up
today so he's supposed to be guaranteed
to get it today oh now here's the thing
here's the thing what's this missing
Grandma's body found in Monster python
that swollen or hole in Indonesia I saw
um Josh Thompson posted this yeah that
would be a reticulated python okay
that's a reticulated python 22 feet
well first of all what's the what's the
grandma doing strolling through the
goddamn jungle in Indonesia I gotta see
this can we see it yeah that's correct
well she was a smaller lady hold on
that was cramped up but I mean you could
just see the video here it's not that
that's nice like what the [ __ ] what do
you want me to do this old lady is oh
that's cool oh ate her clothes and
everything
oh dude that's so insane yeah
I don't know whoa
that's missing grandma that's a bad way
to go God damn is it ever 22 foot long
python you got eaten think how fast it
should probably just stumble upon it and
well you know what they do would they
bite you they wrap you she fell down
break all your bones and every time you
breathe in watch you breathe in and
every time you breathe out they get
tighter now you're like
and then it's like having a mock on you
they feel you that's right that sucks
how long does it take you to die a while
well I assume if you're that old the
bones are pretty fragile so you get you
just you die of asphyxiation she's only
54 I thought I was gonna be older what
she's a you're younger than me I know
that's not a grandma I thought I was
thinking about 80. she's still Grandma
but not like old grandma my thing is is
hold on the snake lightly big how'd they
find it likely better and then suffocate
her by wrapping itself around her before
27 foot it would have taken at least two
hours how would you know that she's in a
snake's belly well they came across like
oh that snake looks pretty thick it's
almost the same size hippo eyes oh God
here we go it was on Newsweek okay
it's a shame to kill an animal that big
but it's also uh Anaconda python yeah
it's a python doing python [ __ ] yes
you're killing him for what she's the
one that took the rest and walked in the
jungle I will say though the kids are at
risk all everybody's at risk for a
python that big
though
no no I'll give I'll punch that thing in
the [ __ ] when I'm biting go ahead
we're going to wrap me up when I went
python I have to say grabbing a 10-foot
python is crazy now I saw an article
that said a 13 year old caught 22
pythons like won some contest yeah I
thought about you catching one yeah well
it depends on the time of year and day
hmm they come out during the day they
like the Sunday uh you gotta do it at
specific times early early in the
morning
Kanye West he's no longer a billionaire
boy I'll tell you what man you know when
he did the White lives matter I was like
all right that's not great but he'll
survive that when he went after the Jews
I was like well now you're done [ __ ]
up now you done [ __ ] up because you
know homeboy at WME came after him it
was like any any business that works
with them that works with this and you
continue to work with Kanye we're
dropping from our agency who said I
think it was the CIA no it's WME
was his agency but WME do you know what
I'm talking about yeah
manual is Jewish yes and um many of the
people that work there are the people
that runs how powerful is Ari Emmanuel
yeah so you've seen you've seen
Entourage right Jeremy Pittman's
character is based off Aria Manuel yeah
so all right manual owns Julia Morris
Endeavor which means he owns the UFC as
well and many more things and they work
with the biggest people in the world so
when he puts out a email blast I don't
know you only put out a fast which is
what they put on Salman Rushdie what the
Ayatollah put on some it's like it's
like if you do business with this guy
then you if you're a friend of his job
who's saying things like guminati Jewish
meeting not good and all that not good
and and saying I'm gonna go Defcon three
on Jewish people let me explain what
that means what you're saying is that
you're gonna you're gonna use military
might so Defcon 3 is when your air force
is ready to launch missiles you're five
minutes or something it's okay that's a
term of War if you're Jewish and by the
way he's got McCain's got not only a
huge following but a lot of people that
Echo that sentiment So when you say I'm
about to go Defcon 3 on Jewish people
I'm I'm sorry but there are a couple
things to keep in mind historically that
doesn't work out for the Jews
historically that's how you whip up a
mob and they kill the Jews well that's
that's why and you're you are
threatening the Jews with violence when
you say that you're threat if you're
Jewish if you're a Jewish person you're
gonna go well that's that's calling
that's a one of the most popular artists
in the world calling for violence
against Jewish people who has a huge you
can say whatever you want but that is
what you're gonna be explained why the
Jews don't play that game there's a
history if they don't if they don't
anti-semitic like if they don't raise
the flags here if they don't if they
don't say something happened they get
killed oh you're talking about World War
best they get kicked in Russia the
Russian pale World War II they were the
original refugees the Old Testament is
how they they escape from Egypt the
story of the Jewish diaspora is that
story so you just gotta understand that
to be first of all the Jews are a true
minority they make a 0.01 of the [ __ ]
world population that's the thing
they're such a small minority they have
to stick up for themselves and when they
stick up for themselves they're very
powerful so when you go for them dude um
when he did that I went oh it's a game
because because it's a matter for for
the Jews life or death it's a matter of
life and death let me just but I let me
just go on a little bit of a rant not
too much because I don't want to do this
not too much but if you guys like comedy
do you like improv do you like Hollywood
do you like fashion in this country and
do you like stand-up comedy
the borsche belt said stamp coming the
boar spell uh improv the borsche belt
which was in the Catskills all those
comics
all the comics like that people watched
all those shows and stuff those kids
were Jews they came from they would put
up on put all the musicals all the great
writers
Sondheim Sondheim
who who wrote uh I don't know Les
Miserables I mean Broadway
and Hollywood I'm I'm I'm telling you
Broadway and Hollywood
and the Art of Improv
and stand-up comedy in this country I'm
not saying the British didn't have an
amazing impact on Comedy but but but but
but but those were Jewish Expressions
the great the the garmentos the people
that came to this country and started
fashion like Ralph Lauren was Ralph
lifshitz
Calvin Klein Jewish they came to this
country the people that came for this
country who created Hollywood you know
Hollywood you guys like movies they were
Eastern European refugees they didn't
come from money they lived in the Lower
East Side they lived in poverty and that
is a [ __ ] historical fact
the the Garment business the Garment
industry the fashion industry in this
country
started by Jews they didn't have money
the only thing they had they're only in
Europe they weren't allowed to be in
banking and things they could be Tailors
and seamstresses so they came to this
country with a skill set which was they
could sell fashion yep but think about
what what was created in Hollywood The
Improv was Second City was founded by
the children of Russian and Eastern
Europe Jewish refugees so if you like
Saturday Night Live
if you like Mad TV if you like any
sketch shows if you like stand-up comedy
your favorite comedy show yes you're
your favorite comedy movie Yes those
were that that was those were Jewish
Expressions yes John Apatow so so I'm
sorry I'm sorry that this tiny minority
is that [ __ ] good at inventing [ __ ]
that all of us use but that's why
they're so hated too right because
they're they're everyone hates do you
use Google and that that algorithm was
was created by Jews do you use Facebook
created by a Jews I mean you know so I'm
sorry that they're that good if if you
if you have a problem with juice that's
fine but go look at what they've
invented like virtual reality do you
like virtual reality yourself before you
hate them because most likely you're
using their products and you're
benefiting off their products and their
entertainment yes most of the shows
you're watching was created by Drew the
writers are probably Jewish all the
things that you do on a daily basis is
probably influenced by the Jews yes and
so they they were always the ones on the
outside looking and during the Civil
Rights Movement one more step during the
Civil Rights Movement the people that
marched for blacks in this country half
the white volunteers half of them were
Jewish and why is that because they know
what this what the road that goes down
there when you're on the here you went
yes when you've always been on the
Forefront of social change people are
gonna [ __ ] hate you there's
a lot to it there's a lot when Kanye did
that now you've got to educate himself
and well yeah yes and no I you know I
think he's always been like this you
know TMZ said you know when he was
talking about uh black people you know
they need to take ownership of slavery
or whatever he's saying about slavery
remember that you know they had to edit
most of that out you know his real
stance was he's a fan of Hitler do you
know this I I just can't believe he
would say that
TMZ started by a Jew yes we can just
keep going yeah because they you because
you guys remember the infamous uh
interview and when he's like you know
they need to figure out
so so that gentleman on the left see the
gentleman on the left van Lathan he left
TMZ but he was the main one to speak out
and walk out of the room when Kanye was
saying how you know uh basically slavery
was black people's fault and blah blah
blah so they in that interview TMZ was
like we got to do Kanye a solid here
they had to edit it out because he said
he was a fan of Hitler now that's
according to this van guy which I don't
believe he has any reason to lie now
what's happening too is Adidas dropped
them now Adidas they make the majority
of the money off of the Yeezy brand oh
wow it's a huge hit to them but they're
like we can't we can't engage in this so
Balenciaga dropped them right
Adidas dropped them they say he's no
longer a billionaire anymore that's how
much he's losing in assets right now
he's no longer is he losing his mind
because he can't see his kids is that
what's going on is he trying to
self-destruct here there's nothing to do
with kids you think it has to tell you
is he trying to break contracts he's
trying to get out of contracts he had no
no because he's just royally [ __ ]
himself like there's no way because he's
smart smart one thing I say about you
can't say he's stupid smart so you know
it's weird you know we got to be careful
here because when you go oh it's uh just
a manic uh phase it's not he's on one of
those manic episodes so is there a
method but then there's also like but
he's a genius all right well which one
is he you pick because he can't when he
does something bad he can't just be
always having one of his uh episodes
then when he does some great oh he's a
genius I don't think it's that I I truly
believe he he has those ideologies and
those ideas we'll keep this in mind too
which is a problem and there's a lot of
it is what it is it's not my belief and
I don't describe this in any [ __ ]
facet I have some of my best friends are
Jewish
there's some uh black people in the
spotlight who also have the same beliefs
when it comes to Jews that blacks are
the first Jews and you know stuff like
that so because Moses his second wife
was from Ethiopia or but they're just
they're not loud about it but there's
again I'm not bringing attention to it
but there's some
very high profile people that are black
who believe the same things I was about
to say to you that a lot of people Echo
his sentiment all over the world don't
kid yourself Kanye gets a lot of support
for when he says stuff like that well
Andrew Schultz and uh the flagrant boys
that shout out to Andrew they talked
about Conan Andrew went hard on them
stuff like that and he's talking about
the George Floyd stuff and blah blah and
then she's like I can't believe the
comments like there was a lot of support
for Connie because you know I have
friends who love Kanye well my thing
with the black I've ever wore my easy
yeah since the White lives matter thing
I was like all right I'm still gonna
wear Yeezys he that was weird and I do
like Candace Owens but still I'm still
gonna wear my ease the only did the
anti-jew thing I can't really use these
so my best friends are Jewish dude yeah
a lot of people that are responsible for
the success of my career and decision
makings and contracts and getting me
certain things are Jewish yeah and
they're great people yeah so when you do
that I'm like well now I'm out dude now
it's just not helpful man it's just it's
just
when you if you were to say this if you
were to say I'm gonna go Defcon 3 on on
uh lights on the on the Zionist movement
in Israel or you were to say I'm gonna
go Defcon 3 on the is the likud party in
Israel if you were really specific and
you're like the conservative Hawks I
don't know
it'd be one thing because you'd have
doves that would come you know in Israel
that would come to your defense but when
you say I'm gonna go Defcon 3 on Jewish
people the black the entire group of
people you know yeah Michael Rapaport
said something interesting posted a
picture of of uh Drake and say how come
and said how come this Jewish man has
been so quiet because Drake's mother's
Jewish well hold on now what's
interesting is in that same rant that
Kanye had like I'm in all this trouble
he on the the drinking Bros podcast I
think was a huge platform in hip-hop
huge show great show but uh Kanye goes
the best rapper to ever do it's Drake
now Drake is Jewish
drink is half Jewish right yes he is his
religious mother is Jewish and he's
Jewish yeah
so you say the greatest rapper Jewish
right right right raised Jewish
but then you go on this deaf raise
Jewish in in Canada I believe right I
see from Toronto Toronto yeah so Drake
is not a not uh Drake's not a ghetto
like he does that's his cultures
educated Jewish uh Drake grew up in uh
entertainment he was on a TV show so
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah so
but why has he been so quiet that's a
weird place for him to be uh I I don't
know if you want to touch that water
like like P Diddy came to the defense of
Kanye and Connie just posts his text
might give her [ __ ] company but
talking [ __ ] if he did him P Diddy was
like I think what he's saying he gets
misconstrued like he was literally
trying to defend him and then Kanye
posts his text and was like [ __ ] you
don't bring my name up but you'll see
what happens and PJ's like dude I was on
your side but it'd be tough to defend
him it'd be like if a comic did this
even if it's a good friend
I'm not going to add fuel to the fire
yeah but I'm not going to defend it if
if you did something like that yeah I
can't be so I don't want any part of
that hey you're wrong yeah and you need
to apologize but she's not doing right
right and and then you know C it's like
I'm not going to throw more uh fire few
on the fire but I'm I'm sure sure as
[ __ ] not sticking out for you I'm
probably gonna do the Drake and she's
like he knows he I don't need to say
anything what happens to Kanye a year
from now he's back now Spotify did say
they don't agree with anything he says
it's horrible but they're not pulling
his music
but the rest of it like he had this big
documentary coming out Jews producing
that pulled that CA pulled that you have
uh you know it's gonna get dicey man now
he's gonna be fine right the money-wise
he's fine but it's it's ultimate man did
you [ __ ] up dude man did you mess up
what were you thinking and it's coming
in and I know what he was saying he was
thinking about a lot of people and I'm a
fan he was thinking about a lot of
people in the world think that's the
problem
a lot of uneducated stupid people
there's a lot of answers and you have
all the resources in the world you what
you need is a better team around you
have all the resources in the world I
see kind of you know this from time to I
see the people around you should be
ashamed of themselves that they allowed
you I don't think he's controllable I
don't think you even know what the [ __ ]
he's gonna do ever I don't think I think
the minute you tell them what to do you
get fired I don't the problem with with
power like that is you surround yourself
with people who are looking for a
paycheck and they just know they're
dealing with crazy and they just yes you
to death so they get the money but
that's probably Yes Man like that's what
he does well I'd say can you imagine
listen Joe Rogan's not as influence uh
he's not as big or as as I don't know as
much influence as Kanye West Kanye West
is real he's our Steve Jobs of rap right
he's our Steve Jobs of entertainment
Rogan's definitely influential when it
comes to commenting podcasting
but even Rogan has more money than God
but if Rogan posts some or something
anything
you can call Rogan I'm like what are you
doing I'm like God you're [ __ ] right
dude that's what I'm saying I've had
times where like Rogan we'd all do that
for each other well like if I say you
you've done that and I've done it to you
you've done it to me multiple times
Rogan did to me like when I was in this
got so out of hand with the the
conspiracy with Dana and stuff like that
yeah caught me joking around joking
around they just got a hand but you were
trying to create it but then when you
put my but then when you put me against
the wall I'm like hold on hold on here
dude I do con I do nine shows a [ __ ]
week this is some for me to run with and
it gives me entertainment and I caveat
with I don't believe all this but if I
were going yes I do that's right and
then Dana picks it up and I do stuff and
even Brogan was like what are you doing
dude why would a [ __ ] make a bit about
it I'm like I I need con like for me
it's fun yeah and I was like you know I
still don't dislike Dana all right funny
goes don't do that one all right you're
right and then when he goes on show and
goes oh Brent needs a Handler and my
friends and family call me like the
Roman senior Handler I called him I text
him he was I tried calling him text him
I was like hey are you kidding me dude
Handler and then he wrote me this long
team like you're right should have said
that you know but and he gave me his
reason I went I know but you don't need
he was right he shouldn't said that
you're not helping my cause dude I'm
already fighting a good fight here
you're not helping me he said you're
right don't do it again this guy would
never do that to you ever do
but that's what you you do the same
thing why are you doing talking about
podcasts and being silly I get maybe out
of line like I don't know we all do it
you call me dude I listen to that
whatever is Breakfast Club whatever dude
I list you on flagrant what are you
doing dude the [ __ ] I'm like you're so
right yeah look at this one oh you're
right and then we never do it again well
that's what you have friends Connie
doesn't have that yeah
yeah but my point is
Rogan's [ __ ] massive yeah but he has
no problem admitting is wrong ever and
and no problem adjusting his approach
well the difference not self-destructive
this is strange self-destructure you
could you could it's like being drunk
and saying you you have such an
influence like if you came out like man
I've been like kind of Nick Cannon
remember Nick Cannon did the same thing
and then he went on this tour and he he
went to uh some Jewish sites and educate
himself on the history was like Oh I
thought you know what I [ __ ] up man
why why did he do this what was the
impetus going on bad on Jews you know
no no no no it's not a it's it's not a
one-day theme oh I don't like Jews this
is you know going off for a long time
because a lot of the people who run the
music industry and all that um
so if you're looking for an enemy
remember it's it's a numbers game who
controls like who like your agent now I
don't know what he is my agents have
always been Jewish one of my best
friends taught film is Jewish he's one
of the head of CA all the people in say
are Jewish so let's say someone did me
wrong or I made a bad mistake and it's
my fault I'm not selling tickets now
right well who am I going to point the
gun who who am I going to point the The
Smoking Gun at
CA which isn't right yeah it's it's a me
problem but if I want to blame someone
or I'm gonna blame these agents well in
the field of representative in
entertainment Comics actors podcasters
YouTubers who's those agents majority
are Jewish so you have resentment
against them they're the Enemy No No
Maybe one guy did you wrong it's not a
Jewish thing that's that guy's thing
I don't know man
my brother's the biggest guy he will
blow your mind how much he knows about
Kanye blow your mind I'm a I'm a kind of
I'm more of a drake fan but as far as
influence influential as far as your
creator but fashion too like Drake
Fashion's awful his merch is terrible
thick boy runs circles around him but
Kanye's destroys everybody and what he's
done and changed the game and all this
stuff like there's nobody been like
Kanye man yeah you know so it's like
it's it's such a shame and I'm listen I
I put up with a lot when when it comes
to these people and you know you've
never known media is trying to shame
stuff like that and I see that stuff a
mile away but when it comes to you want
to be anti-semitic I'm out dude you're
not gonna see me wear Yeezys until you
apologize yeah
yeah but and uh for Connie if you just
apologize your followers go oh that's
what a grown man does that's what a good
person does that's what he's not manic
depressed if he's not having one of his
episodes oh he oh he made a mistake
because I think it's uh I think it
sounds like uh this this weird
anti-self-destructive Behavior it's this
it's almost like a form of it's like
it's like being on the uh fringes of
suicide like you're you're it's a form
of suicide and you're a billionaire what
are you crying for yeah it's a form of
amazing what other point do you have to
prove you [ __ ] made it to
so think about it your fan base went
through all the Maga stuff yeah the
Trump stuff all this crazy [ __ ] right
still here he's still here this is the
one man well this is man I mean you know
you say that this is also the thing that
can get him don't be surprised if he
gets more followers
that's what's crazy about it see that's
what the juice when you're Jewish when
you're Jewish what you really know what
you really understand
no the conversation is this
I guarantee most Jews if you showed if
you said hey look Kanye's following went
up Jewish people would be like that's
the problem I we know I agree we know
that's what's so dangerous about this
you do that and you get more love you
don't get more hate that's what's crazy
right you got to realize it's a very big
world out you know what else happened
they pulled his tour into they pulled
his they pulled he was supposed to I
think it's Mass Square Garden or
somewhere in La again people that organ
whether it's Outback whether it's Live
Nation who runs those beats you know I
work with Live Nation Al back Jewish
well they they don't care how much this
isn't a money thing for them they'll get
their money somewhere again it's life
and death yes so they're like oh we
won't no absolutely not all right well
you know that that's it's such a shame
and all you got to do is educate
yourself know the history of Jews and
you would have so much respect Kanye
because you think you came from nothing
Bella you think you came from the depths
of Hell to get to where you're at
educate yourself on the Jewish being
what they went through
what are you talking about dude you have
so much respect for them and if he went
you know I educated myself I dude man
did I I didn't know oh my God I didn't I
didn't I had no idea and then if you
apologize then we can all move on yeah
yes people burning Yeezys on social
media like you know you [ __ ] up dude
it's such a shame very interesting man
what else you got chin that's a long way
out of Kanye but it's well needed
this is kind of difficult to watch but
it's uh I don't know if you've seen this
video yet it's a police officer shooting
a a teenager in a car and he was just
literally at a McDonald's with his
friend eating a hamburger oh I don't
like this oh but he was driving off but
he's driving but he's okay though right
no no he died no he's like he's not dead
but I think he's still in critical
conditions
um yeah so when you watch this video it
just it makes no sense why this uh cop
would shoot at him
thank you
get out of the car what
oh
that's on fire shots fired shots fired
shots fired that makes no sense zero
sense so I guess he was responding to a
different call
and then they're also saying that this
officer thought that this was a car that
got away from him a day before
okay it makes zero sense why he would
shoot him take off I guess he was just
freaking out
I mean if a cop just opened your door
and you're eating a hamburger and he's
got a gun I don't know dude he shot his
whole clip in that kid yeah what
do you think well I got fired yeah yeah
excuse me his buddy was in the car it's
a girl it was a girlfriend you got that
cop is a dum dum kids I'm dumb and the
kids in critical condition yeah the last
I heard it was incredible she's gonna
open fire
you know me I always stick by cops we
watch this like what the [ __ ] you
thinking no no what are you doing nobody
there I stand by cops too but there are
a lot of cops that see that and be like
hey hey amateur hey dumb dumb is that
Julia Robert's daughter
no that's Julie Roberts no that's his
daughter this right here yeah that's
fake no that's that's Julia Roberts
that's an ad yeah it's fake but uh so he
was
but but here's the thing too with cops
to defend copter that guy's the 0.01
that [ __ ] most of them would never do
that yeah
yeah it just didn't make any sense why
you do that stomach diaphragm lungs
liver biceps Jesus and hearts well
unload an entire clip hey [ __ ] face near
his heart
Jesus what are you doing dude what else
you got Jen yeah that was pretty crazy
um let's lighten the mood here
[ __ ] give that guy with the big wiener
yeah let's go biggest wiener in the
world he has the world's largest penis
and it's still growing according to him
now this is my only caveat here it says
it's eight inches thick hard I think
circumference
um yeah so 13.5 inches long which is
freaking insane he's not terribly
attractive well no when God was gonna
have wieners you know you know what
you're getting all the wiener because
face and body we're gonna have to look
at that we're gonna have to knock you on
that yeah look at that big dick is it
fake no no no no no so Mark had to go to
get his passport Mark actually the movie
with this guy who said he's like
basically on the Spectrum okay which is
giant wiener all right well you know I I
tell you who's got him no I I don't want
to match him not us look at that the
game
no no 13.5 inches not no he's literally
he's world record holder now
um I would assume that that big winner
you know cool eyes I've assume that big
wiener goes in I don't want to draw the
conclusion I see that I assume that
winner goes in men's butts right I don't
know is he straight or give you the
pictures I mean tell me
he said that he had sex with certain
porn stars because they're just so
intrigued by how big his dick is and
even celebrities too I feel like I've
seen some black guys on the important
Hub with bigger dicks well go to the
game but this is like it's games guys
classic the game's got it he's going
down
hmm
that was just a joke yeah I understand
go to the game for a second okay
the game's got it
oh yeah when you do that hashtag happy
Monday big dick or whatever it was I
mean Halloween
said now now he definitely chubbed that
thing up but that thing is hard well oh
no don't get me wrong that thing he's
he's dimed up too I love the tats but um
but the other guys nothing's chopped up
that guy is like embarrassed of it
what's up with him posting pictures of
his dick though no it was a it was a he
did as a joke he was like hey happy
Monday get your copy hashtag big dick
hashtag digpic you know it was hilarious
it's great yeah yeah he had he had a
heater on him man he's got nothing yeah
look at that picture down there that
that [ __ ] that come on which one go
back to that look at the where we're in
the white we're in the white shorts
right there holding on to it up there
oh I see it yeah upstairs
yeah like that's see that's aggressive
that looks Photoshop but it ain't
this one it's going upwards but this one
is going downwards so I don't know
what's going on well you know what I'm
saying this dick is chubbed up you put
the hashtag time to break the internet
again hashtag what's he doing for you
hashtag he don't take care of your kids
hashtag he lick it from the front to the
back
as you slip under that [ __ ] like a
mechanic and turn it up with his tongue
#and he bet not say Valentine's Day is
both of us
um hashtag it it's for women hashtag now
handle your business before I do has to
actually deserves a five thousand dollar
purse I should actually do those flowers
every day what are you trying to [ __ ]
all the girls hashtag what she has it's
funny hashtag so make her look like
she's Styles
black guy doing it wait either [ __ ]
like she made Jesus The Last Supper
oh that's good
yeah
there's another guy I guess there's
there's like a documentary or something
that's coming out with that guy and
another guy yeah I missed that people
with huge dicks so this guy I I just
want the cliff notes on that what's
going on with this guy he said he lost a
job opportunity because they thought
that during the interview they thought
he was getting a hard on it well he's he
was and he's weird and
and oh my God now my win what's funny
he's white and skinny which is hilarious
yeah yeah he's so skinny oh just like
those usually the guys though yep those
are the guys in the porns with the big
old bazookas the amphetamine sucked in
that performance against doctor oh did
you see it no I don't know how you could
vote for him now is he better than Dr Oz
probably but the thing is he had that
stroke and when they were asking about
uh fracking and stuff
he had one of his you know issues
well we can't vote for this guy he did
oh it's too bad well he's just like you
could see like
uh
he's just he's trying to figure out he's
like yes to fracking like what this is
crazy yeah okay I don't even know Alexis
were too heavy but I mean the way she
controls it is insane so I'll just play
what's going on here so this is her
residency I think she's a robot yeah
yeah I would go to this I'm a huge Kitty
paper I think she's hot as far oh she's
definitely I'm not a huge fan of her
music she I think she's so hot oh you
don't like maybe you're a five well
that's my favorite song in the world but
oh man one of mine
at work
yeah firework yeah fireworks hear me
roar come on dude her acapella douche
she can sing but I don't care all right
let me see her become a robot those are
unbelievable tits look at her eyes
oh well keep watching though why does
she keep hitting like a button on the
side I know
whoa it's so crazy oh maybe because is
it is it being held up
is it being held up with like it looks
like because she kept going like this
I don't know my wife told me it's
because her eyelashes were too heavy
like there was some kind of a oh no
that's stupid no I well you so only once
include thing or something I don't know
but then why is she going like she's
hitting like a button going yeah and I
was like this shoes no I think she was
gonna like this to me she's going maybe
there's a muscle spasm that's what I
think but or or like I know I think so
no I think what happened she had some
work done and I think your eyelashes can
be heavy so your eyelash you can have
too much glue and if your muscles aren't
used to it your muscles don't they get
exhausted they don't they well they
don't connect they don't communicate
yeah so you're using the same amount of
muscle here but you stop using it here
and all of a sudden you get weighed down
you're like huh my only my only caveat
with that shoot pulled off and pop up
she was pressing a button can't pull
those off she's pressing the button
she's RoboCop going like this she might
be a robot
it does look like she's a robot Katy
Perry might not be real she might be a
Scion I'll buy one so will I oh my boy
oh boy I would too she's I think she's
bring her up let me see some pictures of
her in something yeah that's cool she's
so pretty and American Idol you go wait
a minute is that photoshop pretty short
here I do oh no I love her short hair
and Orlando Bloom you know he's lighting
the pants he I've I've met him he's he's
like I flew on a plane I look like him
compared to you yes and and
she's a nice guy but she's this is so
hot
girls she's a lot bigger than Orlando he
is too light in the ass for that don't
cut your hair like that right that is
her hold on that's her all right not the
best that's all right wait hold on just
hold that for a second I gotta get over
my Katy Perry this is where celebrities
look real normal they're just like us
you look they are you looking at him and
you go okay but when she's glammed up
well it's very interesting uh can you
back to that I gotta just take that in
for a second that's the most
unflattering bathing suit I've ever seen
in my entire [ __ ] life but now to be
fair she could have just had the baby so
then she has a little extra tummy there
so she's wearing the hospital yeah
that's fair that's fair okay what else
that let's not show that picture
the Rockets up top though some people
look bad and can't stop won't stop yeah
oh my God is some of this photoshopped
Bubba no don't ruin this shouldn't move
on I'm asking a question wait here's
another one question
there you go I'm not mad at that one no
no that's cool what's that Mom the
onesie
uh this is just a a group of guys that
live at a house they're catalytic
converter for one of their trucks was
getting stolen and they just shot these
guys with the paintball gun
we have video and lighting them up so
they have a Ford Excursion don't drive
that though right because it's four
miles a gallon and these two guys they
have something called a they get they're
good at it they do it quick yeah
so they're going at it right now
I'll fast forward I mean it's just the
middle of the damn date on a busy street
so people listening busy Street Normal
suburb and they just start shooting them
yep they probably think it's gone yep
they got the converter though
oh they still got it
oh there he is
oh wow now that that one guy with the
bald head's too old to have a roommate
right
yeah that's the that's exactly what I
was thinking too like they're [ __ ]
almost three guys yeah why why would you
slow down that was kind of sucky how'd
you'll mess up their car
enjoy that Cadillac converter when you
get to sell it to pay for your back
window and so it's only like they sell
for like a few hundred bullets Brian in
three years but this is kind of crazy so
this guy this guy was considered the
world's dirtiest man he never wanted to
take a shower and everyone think about
because he thought he's gonna get sick
so villagers eventually convinced him to
take a bath and then he died shortly
after don't let my son see this he's 94
too so now you know but still it's just
time to die boy I bet you he smelled
like pure [ __ ] 94 and he never took a
bath nope and he was still alive
I don't even know if he was 94 he's
probably 30 it's hard living yeah maybe
in 34. oh there he is it well his
pillow's a rock right so it's not like
he had the best pillows Rock
emotional setbacks he's drinking avocado
yeah he's drinking out of a carburetor
right there so it's not like he's
getting the best nutrition but 94 doing
the damn thing was doing the damping was
took a bath killed him I've been shocked
if I went to shock from the clean this
one it's not this old but I still find
this fascinating that Byron Allen is
this Rich because I would just see him
late night TV with Like Comics he would
have Comics together he was a producer
but he's also stand up right yeah but
yeah
he'll stop like weird showing like the
WGN super nice guy yeah I liked I I've
actually met him yeah so he bought 100
million dollar mansion it's the biggest
home sale ever you know how much money
you have to have to put down camera 200
million so at least to a hundred million
dollars why would you buy a house that
much
no that's probably a good investment now
but especially with beachfront the big
property yeah because it's only going up
yeah I mean now there's only about seven
people that work to buy yeah that's
that's a castle
uh I mean kind of it depends on the line
it's all about the land of Malibu can I
see more pictures of that I mean I yeah
I mean I don't know yet see how big that
yard is and I'll and see the front yard
okay well that's lit but it's also 100
million dollars I mean 100 million it
seems a little bit oh see see but your
backyard's the ocean right and then you
got all that land that's why it's so
much because in Malibu the land is so
can't that for 20 mil if you go up the
street yeah go go two blocks that way 20
mil but now you want beachfront Daddy
man 80 mil extra it's a lot that's a lot
of like like a hundred mil how much
would that cost well you got a hundred
million dollars oh
got it
okay that place is ridiculous I know but
I've seen houses for five million
dollars oh me too yeah you know what I'm
saying but it's location Daddy and the
the property I get it like the full
tennis court and on the beach well you
know all the way it's Courtney Cox house
is like that but it's not a hundred
Mills now I don't know that place is
nuts as far as lands what else you got
Jen
so this is a only fans girl and then her
her thing is like she believes it's good
to have sex on the first date so all the
awkward stuff goes away right away yeah
I watched me I watch uh what she's oh
she's an old defense model hey Kazumi no
can you see that can I see the video
though because she's like I have sex but
it's just a show you in baggie events
and see what's underneath
yeah it's just a little video yeah so
there you go
looks like she's not 100 million dollar
mansion yeah yeah and and and that's oh
okay and she reportedly makes 250 000 a
month sure yeah I probably hear 50 of
that
yeah yeah there's her Instagram
or one of her Instagrams well she's
she's right there she's professional as
are the other girls and I bet you're
gonna learn three of them yeah is that a
porn set no that looks like a uh podcast
that they did
yeah she does can I may I go back to
that picture again of the yeah now keep
going I like the one on the far left
actually I don't know I was just gonna
say who would like the one on the far
left and there you are I just think
she's
I don't know she just looks like she's
ready to rock and roll that's a good
tattoo and I know she's a virgin but
still like I you know
yeah she's oh yeah I'm not mad at her
these are better pictures all right Fair
Point that's it all right well I also uh
sleep with dudes on the first night I'm
in uh Calgary this Thursday Friday
tickets are uh only left for Friday
that's this week and then next week's
Antonio LOL San Antonio Texas November
3rd through the 5th and then the week
after uh Texas again Houston Texas
Houston Improv uh November 10th through
the 12th also in San Antonio Houston
also Calgary hopefully if shipping's
cool but especially in San Antonio
Houston it will be an extra thick tiger
thick nectar sweet uh whiskey the
award-winning whiskey batch two is here
we'll have all the cases in San Antonio
and Houston Houston I'm doing the
parents at the specs out there for Tiger
thick so we're gonna have Target the
cats tasting uh appearances come get a
picture whatever the hell you guys want
to do try that sweet award-winning tiger
thick nectar but come get a bottle if
you want one in Calgary Santo Houston
Texas tickets at thickboy.com
Providence Rhode Island Washington DC DC
Improv but Calgary Europe San Antonio
Houston coming up next thick boy.com B
guys Chicago improv this weekend October
27 tomorrow next day next day Comedy
Zone Charlotte North Carolina by the way
Chicago improv it's in Schaumburg let's
go their tickets left for Thursday
Friday some Saturday uh Charlotte North
Carolina Comedy Zone November 10 11 12.
Addison Texas Addison Improv November 17
18 19 Naples Florida off the hook comedy
December one two three and four and as
usual my special man tears dropped check
it out but only if you like laughing
hard hard I kid love you this fine kid
we're out